that it's interesting to notice that
when The Magicians are doing the plagues
it's funny that they just reproduce the
plague which is causing them harm
instead of healing the plague right
they're not stopping the plague they're
just showing that they can do the same
and so they're actually increasing the
plague through their magic rather than
than stopping it because you'll see
right in the story of Exodus you'll see
places where the the Israelites have
issues and God solves their issues like
he helps them it's not like the you know
I don't know the snakes in the desert
riding the Israelites and it's like oh
this is a sign from God so Moses shows
uh he can make snakes also bite the
Israelites no it's like God is healing
them but here The Magicians just repeat
the same magic in and ultimately harming
their own land at the same time so it's
very interesting to see that
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone as you can see I am not
in my usual place I am actually right
now with Jordan Peterson and the daily
wire recording the second part of The
Exodus series
as you know the exited Series has been
daily wire has been putting it out uh
for the past few months I guess coming
out episodes by episode and they told me
to my surprise that it is their most
popular special and it has been watched
by at least two-thirds maybe more of
their I think
I think that's about two-thirds maybe
even three-fourths of their subscribers
which is pretty astounding so I'm pretty
excited to be doing the second part of
this and in the meantime uh we are going
to do our own look at the Exodus
we are at chapter five I'm going to
start with the return of Moses and Aaron
to the Pharaoh uh meeting with him the
pharaoh's resistance ultimately leading
to the 10 plagues I know the ten plagues
are very mysterious for people and so
hopefully this will be uh helpful for
people to realize to see what's going on
so before we start uh a few things
people need to know that it might be
hard for you to know if you're not
following me very carefully the the Q a
that I used to do every month uh it was
difficult to manage and kind of chaotic
and we didn't know how to do it and so
at least for now we've decided to do it
for Patron only just to make it more
intimate and so that people can engage
more I really would like to be able to
engage with the people but when it was
public it would just get crazy with all
the the comments and everything so for
now we're doing it for subscriber only
as you might have noticed I have a new
website we're working on a new brand but
the website is broken and we're working
like mad like crazy to fix it for you
guys and by the end of January we hope
by the end of January we will have
everything together subscribers will be
able to subscribe and get all their
material everything will be back to
normal but for now if you want to access
patreon subscriber only video sadly the
only way to do it properly is is to to
uh support me on patreon rather than
through the website on patreon
everything is there other videos
everything is available and hopefully by
the end of the month this will be true
as well on on the website another great
thing that's happening is that God's dog
is out for people to buy sadly those in
Europe that supported me on Indiegogo
still have not gotten their books don't
worry we are working like mad again to
get this to happen we had serious legal
problems for some reason the UK refused
our vat application and so we were
scrambling to find new Solutions but
don't worry you'll get your books and
for all the others if you haven't gotten
it it's now time to go to godsdog.com
and order it alright so now let's Dive
Into The Exodus
so chapter five
after Moses and Aaron went to pharaoh
and said this is what the Lord the god
of Israel says let my people go so they
may hold a festival to be in the
wilderness
now this is really important and I might
have mentioned this before is that it's
not just that the Israelites are
supposed to go you know and this is
something which will be seen all through
the books of Exodus it's not just about
Freedom which some people sometimes want
to weaponize Exodus to talk about
Freedom it is about freedom but it's not
just Freedom it's freedom from the
tyrant in in order to serve a higher
purpose and so it's free you know
leaving the Pharaoh going through the
Wilderness to worship God that is what
they're asking the Pharaoh and in some
ways that is why it is so dangerous for
the Pharaoh because the Pharaoh wants
the Israelites to just be you know a
tool of his power he wants the
Israelites to be reduced to potential
for his means and if they now go out and
worship the god of the Hebrews at least
the way it's presented in this case it
is dangerous for him because it will
consolidate them as a people and it will
become something like a challenge to his
authority over them
and the Pharaoh said who is the Lord
that I should obey him and let Israel go
I do not know the Lord and I will not
let Israel go
then they said the god of the Hebrews
has met with us now let us take a
three-day Journey Into the Wilderness to
offer sacrifice to the Lord Our God or
he may strike us with plagues or with
the sword
what the king of Egypt said Moses and
Aaron why are you taking the people away
from their labor get back to your work
and Pharaoh said look the people of the
land are now numerous and you are
stopping them from working
the same day Pharaoh gave his order this
order to the slave drivers overseers in
charge of the people you are no longer
to supply the people with straw for
making bricks let them go and gather
their own straw but require them to make
the same number of bricks as before
don't reduce the quota they are lazy
that is why they are crying out let us
go and sacrifice to our God make the
work harder for the people so that they
keep working and pay no attention to
lies
and so here we can see again what the
ferris trying to do he's just trying to
crush them and to make them cogs in his
machine make them work for him and not
have them pay attention to what he says
are lies but not pay attention to what
Moses is calling them to do not pay
attention to worshiping God and you know
changing that they're transforming their
allegiance in that way
um and it's interesting because he says
I do not know God right it's like I do
not know the Lord I'm not connected to
your God I don't care about that I just
want I will be your God he doesn't say
that but you know it's like I am your
God you do what I say I don't want you
to worship something else beside me and
so
um
what's interesting and so then he
basically says that he will
that he will remove the straw from the
bricks and now they will have to get
their own straw to make the bricks
interestingly enough uh Saint Gregor
Misa has a very surprised very powerful
image of what it is that's going on in
this and I think that he captures half
of the symbolism what is happening so
Saint Gregor Misa says that the
Israelites you know kind of bending over
and Gathering clay in order to make
bricks has something to do with with
death or you know we are made out of
clay out of earth and water that is like
the the stuff that makes us up and so
the idea that the Israelites kind of go
down and gather the clay is for him an
image of you know going back down into
the lower things into the desires into
the passions into the things that you
know he imagines the mold of the bricks
where you take the clay you put it into
the bricks and then it empties and you
do it again and it's like the cyclical
thing where you're constantly making
bricks but you're never finished and so
this idea of being a slave of desire and
the desires kind of turning around and
around is the image that he finds in
that and even more fascinatingly enough
at the end of his interpretation he says
that the straw is the chaff the chaff
that will be burned at the end in the
fire and so he sees these two the two
things that are brought together to make
the bricks as clay in the sense of this
kind of wet uh unformed things that are
inside us like our like our desires but
then also these works that are useless
that will be burned away uh by the fire
uh and so very fascinating and it
captures I think half of the symbolism
because the other half has to do with
the Tower of Babel you know the idea of
making taking clay and straw and making
bricks is something which the other
place in scripture where this is
referenced is in the Tower of Babel and
I think that this is to link these
bricks and and the making of these
bricks to the tyranny of the Tower of
Babel into the excess of unity that the
Tower of Babel represented and the
Pharaoh now becomes an image of nimrod
and an image of a tyrant that imposes
his order on the people so you kind of
have these two extremes which is the
extreme of licentiousness and breakdown
and and chaos and also the extreme of
tyranny of the Tower of Babel at the
same time if you follow my work you'll
notice that I often try to show how
often these two opposites appear
together these two extremes of of
civilization and of chaos was ultimately
the image of that of course being the
riding the beast in the Revelation
but the idea that these two things are
related
it's important if you want to understand
these stories
then the slave driver that the overseers
went out and said to the people this is
what the Pharaoh says I will not give
you any more straw go and get your own
straw wherever you can find it but your
work will not be reduced at all so the
people scattered all over Egypt to
gather stubble for use for straw the
slave drivers kept pressing them saying
complete the work required for you for
each day just as when you had straw and
Pharaoh's slave drivers beat the
Israelite overseers they had appointed
demanding why haven't you met your quota
for bricks yesterday or today as before
and so this idea of them Gathering
stubble I think is important and
understanding also the Gathering of clay
in some ways they really are at the
bottom of the world Gathering all this
residue Gathering all this this stuff
that's unformed that's their job and
they're trying to bring it together in
order to become in some ways the support
for Pharaoh's Authority and Pharaoh's
Pharaoh's uh Kingdom
then the Israelites went and appealed to
Pharaoh why have you treated your
servants this way your servants are
given no straw yet we're told make
bricks your servants are being beaten
but the fault is with your own people
Pharaoh said lazy that you are lazy that
is why you keep saying let us go
sacrifice to the Lord now get to work
you will not be given any straw yet you
must produce your full quota of bricks
the Israelite overseers overseers
realize they were in trouble when they
were told you are not to reduce the
number of bricks required for you for
each day
when they left Pharaoh they found Moses
and Aaron waiting to meet them and they
said may the Lord look on you and judge
you you have made us obnoxious to
pharaoh and his officials have put a
sword in their hand to kill us now
another important thing to understand in
this text is that it is in some ways
also secretly you could say or in a
hidden way referring to the Sabbath I'm
pretty sure because there is in some
sense an excess of work and so the
Israelites are asking the pharaoh to let
them set aside a Time To Worship their
God and to stop their work and the
Pharaoh is saying no you must work and
we and you cannot rest you cannot rest
from your work and if you want to rest
I'm actually going to increase your work
and I'm going to subsume you under work
and so you you have to understand that
in relationship to the six days of
creation you know and the number six in
general if you followed a little bit my
my interpretation of the symbolism of of
666 and this idea of creation of
perfection of creation or excess of
perfection in the in the world of work
and of creation and a refusal to have
the the Sabbath and the day of rest
which is set aside which is both rest
but also at the same time uh set aside
for God as a holy thing so this is also
what's going on and so this will it's
also pointing to the to the Commandments
which are coming which will highly
emphasize the idea of the Sabbath as
being important to to the normal cycle
of things
we'll just return to the Lord and said
why Lord have you brought trouble to
this on this people is this why you have
sent me ever since I went to pharaoh to
speak in your name he has brought
trouble on this people and you have not
rescued your people at all
then the Lord said to Moses now you will
see what I will do to Pharaoh because of
my mighty hand he will let them go
because of my mighty hand he will drive
them out of his country
God also said to Moses I am the Lord I
appeared to Abraham to Isaac and Jacob
as God Almighty but by my name the Lord
I did not make myself fully known to
them I also established my Covenant with
them to give them the land of Canaan
where they reside it as foreigners
wherever I have heard the groaning of
the Israelites whom the Egyptians are
enslaving and I have remembered my
Covenant so it's interesting because
what you're seeing in some ways is that
you know God in some way hardening of
the pharaoh's heart and the fact that
the Pharaoh is persecuting you is going
to play a role in me revealing myself
more fully and so he said by my mighty
hand right he will let them go and then
he switches and says you know I didn't
reveal my name to the Patriarchs and I'm
revealing my name which is being itself
right which is I am to you at this
moment and so there's an interesting
sense in which through the slavery
although you know the slavery wasn't
good through the The Tyranny through all
of this is is forged something which
will ultimately as let's say the Ark of
the story uh manifest itself will reveal
uh the name of the Lord and the people
of God ultimately
therefore say to the Israelites
I am the Lord and I will bring you out
from under the Yoke of the Egyptians I
will free you from being slaves to them
and I will redeem you with an
outstretched arm and with Mighty acts of
judgment
I will take you as my own people and I
will be your God then you will know that
I am the Lord your God who brought you
out from under the Yoke of the Egyptians
and I will bring you to the land I swear
with uplifted hand to give to Abraham to
Isaac and Jacob I will give it to you as
a possession I am the Lord
so here we see again the same extension
of what I just said which is before they
entered into Egypt they were not a
people they were a family they were you
know 12 sons of Jacob but now they have
become a people in the foreign land they
have they have multiplied and have
become not yet a people they've kind of
become the at least they've multiplied
and now God has to pull them out of the
tyranny in order to form them as a
people
um and reveal his name in those in that
people so it's a gathering of a body
right this body now it tends up to God
becomes a people but it also reveals the
higher part in in them as well and so
all of that goes together and functions
together
Moses reported this to the Israelites
but they did not listen to him because
of their discouragement and harsh labor
then the Lord said to Moses go tell
Pharaoh king of Egypt to let the
Israelites go out of his country when
Moses said to the Lord
the Israelites will not listen to me why
would Pharaoh listen to me since I speak
with faltering lips
so the rest of the chapter is actually a
genealogy and so I will not read the
entire genealogy but what I will note
mention to you
um
is just one little part of the genealogy
which is a surprising part
uh starting at verse 20
it says amram married his father's
sister
djokabed Who Bore him Aaron and Moses
amram lived 137 years this is important
because in the story of Aaron and Moses
there is uh what in the law would be
considered incest and so you know it's
very important to see that you know if
you listen to what Matthew said
interestingly you know with Jordan
Peterson he really nailed it in terms of
explaining this is that there's a the
question one of the questions in
scripture is about
who is the stranger that loves you
that's the way I think that meteor
phrased it that is what how far can you
engage with otherness or with something
else uh without losing yourself and
finding the right the right uh
the right binding you could say and so
here you see something like a
relationship which is too close but is
also at the origin of of a new world you
could say and so this is something that
you see if you look at the pattern
you'll see that this relationship is
there in many places where there's like
a new beginning you'll see people ask
that question about Adam and Eve right
they say oh how does that work like how
is it that you know the children of Adam
and Eve who were they marrying and the
answer that they're marrying the sisters
you know
um but you'll see that at every place
where there's like a major transition of
worlds
you know Abraham is married to his
sister lot had children with his
daughters and there you see it very
clearly because it's like at the end of
the world you know Sodom and gomor is
destroyed I feel like everything is done
and then the restarting is a
relationship that is too close and there
are many versions of that and now again
in the version of Moses and Aaron they
are the result of someone marrying their
father's sister and so it is a a kind of
confused beginning it's like a little
circular thing which restarts or kind of
re-jumps the the symbolism and so this
is something which for Christians will
actually be brought all the way into
Christian symbolism in ways that
sometimes people don't notice and it's
in some ways it will be rectified
because it won't be scandalous the way
that it's scandalous in the bible
stories but in the imagery of the mother
of God you will find that the mother of
God represents in her own symbolism both
the mother of Christ but also the bride
of Christ now it does not imply in any
way an improper relationship between
Christ and his mother as they were both
virgins but what it does is it takes the
symbolism of the relationship of a kind
of very close relationship where she's
all at the same time his mother and his
bride and it elevates it in a way that
avoids the Scandal but helps you
understand the symbolism of a new
beginning or something that is both the
end and the beginning at the same time
so this symbolism is very important and
we'll see later in Exodus how you know
the question of the the wife and the
wife that's too close to the wife that's
too far will appear in different places
but and of course in the rest of the
Bible you know there's you know many
stories about that whether it's you know
Solomon who had too many strange wives
you know there are all kinds of versions
of this this story of how it is you know
the idea of finding the proper uh the
proper uh
the proper potential the proper body
with which to engage all right
so then the Lord said to Moses see I've
made you like God to pharaoh and your
brother Aaron will be your Prophet you
are to say everything I command to you
and your brother Aaron is to tell
pharaoh to tell the Israelites go out of
this country but I will harden Pharaoh's
heart and though I multiply my signs and
wonders in Egypt he will not listen to
you then I will lay my hand on Egypt and
my with Mighty acts of judgments I will
bring out my divisions my people the
Israelites
and the Egyptians will know that I am
the Lord when I stretch out my hand
against Egypt and bring the Israelites
out of it
Moses and Aaron did just as the Lord
commanded him Moses was 80 years old and
Aaron 83 when they spoke to pharaoh
that's crazy that they were so old we
often can't don't imagine him that old
but yeah pretty wild uh and so
again we see this subsidiarity we see
how in some ways God is already setting
up this interesting hierarchy you know
that uh it's like you are be like God to
fair oh and Aaron will be your Prophet
it's similar to when God said to to
Moses I will be your God and you know
you will be Aaron's God it's very
similar to this you know it's like
setting up a fractal version of the
normal hierarchy of being and so I took
a little version of the way in which it
works at a higher level
um so it's just interesting to see that
happening and being repeated over and
over
um and so then I will I will skip part
of this last little part of course it's
the story it's the same story uh at the
beginning now we see it played out the
snakes become rods the rods become
snakes and the rods of Moses eat the
rods of the Egyptians and so it's
interesting because people often think
that it's the snakes that the snakes ate
the snakes of the others but it's the
rod that eats the the the the staffs eat
the snakes of the others and it's like
the structure that you know the vertical
that Moses and Aaron is proposing the
hierarchy that they're proposing is
shown to be superior than the Egyptian
one and that is why it devours their
staff it's like it it the other one gets
subsumed into it and it's funny because
you could say you know that's ridiculous
right it's like the idea that Egypt will
be subsumed into Israel you know how
silly is that and you know God plays the
long game my friends and uh you know
when the Egyptians converted to
Christianity uh at the beginning of the
Christian era
you can imagine what kind of Celebration
there was in terms of understanding that
the prophecy something the prophecy of
something like the rod of Moses
completely devouring the rod of the
Pharaoh is it happened just took a while
but it did completely happen in every
single way and so it's important to keep
that in mind you know uh sometimes we
your biblical Scholars will kind of mock
these stories and say oh it's just a
bunch it's a bunch of slaves in Egypt
you know these little tribes in Egypt
trying to play themselves off as if
they're better than the Egyptians and
they're just kind of bragging and and
it's it's ridiculous the Egyptians have
no record of this blah blah blah blah
blah but then ultimately
that's what happens ultimately the
Egyptians convert so uh so there you go
all right and so we will move on to the
plagues then the Lord said to Moses
Pharaoh's heart is unyielding he refuses
to let the people go
to Pharaoh in the morning as he goes out
to the river confront him on the bank of
the Nile and take in your hand the staff
that was changed into a snake then say
to him the Lord the god of the Hebrews
has sent me to say to you let my people
go so that they may worship me in the
wilderness but until now you have not
listened this is what the Lord says by
this you will know that I am the Lord
with the staff that is in my hand I will
strike the water of the Nile and if we
change into blood the fish in the Nile
will die and the river will stink the
Egyptians will not be able to drink its
water
the Lord said to Moses tell Aaron take
your staff and stretch out your hand
over the Waters of Egypt over the
streams and canals over the ponds and
all the reservoirs and they will turn to
blood blood will be everywhere in Egypt
even in vessels of wood and Stone
Moses and Aaron did just as God had
commanded he raised his staff in the
presence of pharaoh and his officials
and struck the water of the Nile and all
the water was changed into blood the
fish in the Nile died and the river
smelled so bad that the Egyptians could
not drink its water blood was everywhere
in Egypt
the Egyptian magicians did the same
thing by the secret Arts Pharaoh's heart
became hard he would not listen to Moses
and Aaron just as the Lord had said
instead he turned and went into his
Palace and did not take even this to
heart and all the Egyptians dug along
the Nile to get drinking water because
they could not drink the water from the
river and so
um
you can say in some ways the symbolism
of the first
um plague seems to be related to the
symbolism of all the plagues together
there are some interesting send it from
the Syrian in his commentary on Exodus
make some interesting statements about
that and there's a thing about how the
Egyptians killed the Hebrew babies and
through the Hebrew babies into the Nile
and then the fish ate the Hebrew babies
and he sees this as the beginning of
almost like a redress of the situation
where by changing the water to blood
then all the fish in the The Rivers died
all those fish that ate the the babies
the Hebrew babies so it's an interesting
image that he brings about but
ultimately it has to do with kind of
saturation you know moving from water
which is something like no identity
right or something like uh you know like
purity of identity you could say and
then moving I don't know not Purity it's
something like lack of identity and then
the other one blood which is something
like saturation of identity to something
like you know the fully human liquid you
could say maybe that's the best way to
understand it and so you know we drink
water we don't drink blood of course not
that's the that's the thing you wouldn't
do and so you move from one to the other
right from the
primordial liquid to let's say the
created the final
the most human liquid you could say but
and it also has to do with death of
course it has to I mean because
obviously if blood is outside your body
it is related in many ways to death
But ultimately I think I mentioned this
in the last video it for Christians at
least we have to understand that this is
pointing us straight to the wedding of
Kana straight to Christ changing water
into wine and it can actually help us
understand the wedding of Kana because
at the wedding of Connor Christ
immediately knows when his mother asks
him
to change to provide wine he understands
that by changing water into wine he will
lead to the death of the firstborn and
that's why it's so weird that's why he
says my time has not yet come and so
here in the plagues of Egypt that is
what is now starting is that you know by
changing the river of the Nile to blood
the place where the Hebrew babies were
thrown we are already hinting at the
death of the of the firstborn which is
coming
the interesting thing way to understand
the
the plagues is to really see them uh
structurally
so we're going to go through the plagues
and uh and we're going to start to see
that there's an actual structure in the
way that the plagues are set up and it
has something to do with an undoing of
the world
all right and so seven days passed after
the Lord struck the Nile
then the Lord said to Moses go to
pharaoh and say to him this is what the
Lord says let my people go so that they
may worship me if you refuse to let them
go I will send a plague of frogs on your
whole country the Nile will team with
frog they will come up into your Palace
and your bedroom and onto your bed into
your houses on your officials on your
people and into your Ovens of needing
throws
the frogs will come up on you and your
people and all your officials and the
Lord said to Moses tell Aaron switch out
your hand with your strap over the
streams and canals and ponds and make
frogs come up on the land of Egypt so
Aaron stretched out his hand over the
Waters of Egypt the frogs came up and
covered the land but The Magicians did
the Same by their secret Arts they also
made frogs come up on the land of Egypt
someone pointed out to me recently I
think I saw it in a video that it's
interesting to notice that when The
Magicians are doing the plagues it's
funny that they just reproduce the
plague which is causing them harm and
that instead of healing the plague right
they're not stopping the plague they're
just showing that they can do the same
and so they're actually increasing the
plague through their magic rather than
than stopping it because you'll see
right in the story of Exodus you'll see
places where the the uh the Israelites
have issues and God solves their issues
like he helps them it's not like the you
know I don't know the snakes are in the
desert are biting the Egyptians they're
biting the Israelites and it's like oh
this is a sign from God so Moses shows
that he can make snakes also bite the
Israelites no it's like God is healing
them but here The Magicians just repeat
the same magic in and ultimately harming
their own land at the same time so it's
very interesting to see that
um
and so but what's interesting you can
start to see the structure and I'm going
to tell you what it is you're going to
start to see it is that it's an undoing
of the world from below moving above and
so you know creation manifests itself
from Heaven down to earth and now what
we're seeing is things you know the the
water turning into blood and then out of
this water coming frogs now the frogs
are hybrids they're amphibians they are
monsters ultimately because they live
both on Earth and in water
and this is how Saint Gregor Nissa sees
it he sees the frogs as these this like
half-formed creature this monster that
that is in between water and Earth and
so because of that represents also all
these things from below all our passions
all these desires that we have that are
kind of rising up and taking over all
the aspects of Egyptian life and so it's
important because it says the the Frog's
infect every aspect of the world from
the private to the public you know uh
from food making to the official to the
very hierarchy so we can imagine with
the water turning into blood it's kind
of bubbling and then out come the frogs
and the frogs start to infect
parasitically everything that the entire
structure of the Egyptians
so Pharaoh summoned Moses and Aaron and
said pray to the Lord to take the frogs
away from me and my people and I will
let your people go to offer sacrifice to
the Lord Moses said to Pharaoh I leave
you the honor of setting the time for me
to pray for you and your officials and
your people that you and your house may
be rid of the frogs except for those
that remain in denial tomorrow said
Pharaoh Willis replied it will be as you
say so that you may know that there is
no one like the Lord your God the frogs
will leave you and your houses your
officials and your people they will
remain only in the nightly will be they
will return to the waters and now they
will be contained in Wars it's important
that the way to present is that they're
coming out of the waters right there
kind of coming out of the chaos coming
out of this lower reality and now moving
up and so you know Moses says I'm going
to now re-put them back in the lower
Waters they'll be contained by the Nile
um after Mosin Aaron left Pharaoh Moses
cried out to the Lord and the frogs he
had brought on pharaoh and the Lord did
when Moses asked the frogs died in the
houses in the courtyards and in the
fields they were piled into heaps and
the land reeked of them but when Pharaoh
saw that there was relief he hardened
his heart and would not listen to Moses
and Aaron just as the Lord had said and
the piling of frogs into heaps is
important as well there's a difference
in the Bible between a mountain or a
hierarchy and a heap a heap is like a
fake it's like a mound of something but
it's like a chaotic
Mound it doesn't have order right it's
not a properly ordered thing so it's
like a mass of chaos which is heaped
together and so this idea of heaping
things uh dead things keeping dead
things uh is an image which contrasts to
the notion of a normal uh you know
normal hierarchy of procession from from
a structure
and of course the Pharaoh does not
listen you know the story he will
reiterate that at every single plague
where he at first says he will do it and
then he hardens his heart or his heart
is hardened
um
all right and so the Lord said to Moses
tell Aaron stretch out your staff and
strike the dust of the ground and
throughout the land of Egypt the dust
will become gnats they did this and when
Aaron stretched out his hand with the
staff and struck the dust of the ground
gnats came on people and animals all the
dust through the land of Egypt became
gnats but when The Magicians tried to
produce that the secret Arts they could
not since the nads were on people and
animals everywhere the magician said to
Pharaoh this is the Finger of God but
Pharaoh's heart was hard and he would
not listen just as the Lord had said and
so here interestingly in terms of
structure right out of the water came
the frogs in the creation narrative what
comes out of the water dry gland is
pulled out of the water and so now we're
like a little higher and now we have
another type of chaos which is the
different from the water but which is
dust uh you know like fragmented broken
little pieces you know that's the dust
that is gathered to make Adam but now
the dust Out of the Dust comes these
parasites these insects which now start
to infect everything in in the land
I'll be honest with you I don't totally
understand
why it is that the pharaoh's uh
magicians can't reproduce this miracle I
mean if you have some insides put them
in the comments I will definitely be
looking to read to get a sense if you
can understand why you think that this
particular Miracle the pharaoh's
magicians cannot reproduce and why it is
said that this particular one is the
Finger of God
then the Lord said to Moses get up early
in the morning
and confront the Pharaoh as you go to
the river and say to him this is what
the Lord says let my people go so that
they may worship me if you do not let my
people go I will send swarms of flies on
you and your officials on your people
and on your houses the houses of the
Egyptians we full of flies even the
ground will be covered with them but on
that day I will deal differently with
the land of Goshen when right where my
people live no swarms of flies will be
there so that you will know that I the
Lord am in this land I will make a
distinction between my people and your
people this sign will occur tomorrow the
Lord did this dance swarms of flies
poured into Pharaoh's Palace and into
the houses of his officials throughout
Egypt the land was ruined by the Flies
then Pharaoh summoned Egypt and Aaron
and said go sacrifice your God here in
the land and Moses said that would not
be right sacrifices we offer the Lord
Our God would be detestable to the
Egyptians and if we offer sacrifices
that are detestable in their eyes that
will they not Stone us we must make a
three-day Journey Into the Wilderness to
offer sacrifice to the Lord Our God as
he commanded us
so what's important to understand again
now if you can see it right it's like
frogs these gnats Out of the Dust so now
these flies they're they don't seem to
come out of the ground but they you know
they are kind of mid midsection they
land on things they land on all the the
objects and they ruin everything and so
it's just like one step higher you'll
see like the whole thing is kind of like
moving up towards the heavens kind of
consuming the entirety of creation
and of course this is the the first
place where it says that the land where
the the where the Israelites were Goshen
is set aside is protected right it's
it's different from the Egyptians and so
it becomes like a a preserved little Arc
through the uh through the plagues
all right so Pharaoh agrees to let the
agrees again to let them go and Moses
said he'll pray for them and the Flies
will go away
so you got to skip over that a little
little facts we get to chapter nine then
the Lord said to Moses go to pharaoh and
say to him this is what the Lord the god
of the Hebrew says let my people go so
that they may worship me if you refuse
to let them go and continue to hold them
back the hand of the Lord will bring a
terrible plague on your Livestock in the
fields on your horses donkeys and camels
on your cattle sheeps and goats but the
Lord will make a distinction between the
livestock of Israel and that of Egypt so
now you have again now you have a plague
on the animals right so think about it
really as kind of moving up from from
the water to these ambiguous monsters to
the gnats little gnats then to the Flies
and now the animals you know that are a
little always a little higher up start
to die in the land
and then of course the next plague is
maybe I'm not going to read them I'm
just going to go through the plagues and
then the next plague is the plague of
boils and so now finally what we have is
um
something which affects the humans but
the way it's done the way in which we
get to the moment when it affects the
humans is well I will read it verse 8
then the Lord said to Moses and Aaron
take handfuls of soot from a furnace and
have Moses toss into the air in the
presence of pharaoh it will become find
dust over the land of Egypt and
festering boils will break out and on
people and animals throughout the land
and so what is Moses doing he is taking
residue right taking something like dust
but it's really like the residue from a
fire
um this black ash
and he is now making the transition up
into the sky so until now we kind of
have stuff coming out from below these
parasites these insects then the death
of these animals and now Moses takes
that which is below throws it up into
the sky and now we have something which
affects the humans and we have a disease
and from then on we'll see that it's
going to kind of move up because now
after the the plague of boils which is
this transition up into the heavens now
we have the hail and so now it's a
plague that's coming down from from
above uh
and the hail comes down and it's not
just hail it's like hail and fire and so
it is in some ways the two pillars if
you we haven't seen them yet but you'll
see later in in Exodus when God brings
the Israelites out of out of the out of
Egypt he protects them and he guides
them with two pillars a pillar of water
pillar of cloud and a pillar of fire and
those two kind of separate are like the
two columns right mercy and rigor the
two columns that we find all through all
through scripture these two opposites
that hold like the two uh the the two uh
columns uh of of the temple
um and so this these these are the two
pillars but now what happens is because
the world is being undone these two
pillars are mixed together and so fire
and hail are mixed together the K the
water and fire is mixed together and
this is what it's bringing about the
destruction imagine something like
Samson that takes the two columns and
then crushes them together and that's
how he destroys his enemy well here it's
very similar to that the two columns of
water and fire are being brought
together and mixed and that becomes an
image of the undoing uh the undoing of
the world
so then the Pharaoh you know says this
time verse 27 says this time I have
sinned he said to them the Lord is right
and I and my people are in the wrong
pray to the Lord for we have enough
Thunder and hell I will let you go
you don't have to stay any longer
so Moses says that he will again stop
the the hail and the fire
so there are some details I don't want
to get into all the details uh some of
them are also a little bit difficult to
understand that I even on myself I I
struggle to understand that clearly has
meaning
I still need to think about
so of course when Pharaoh sees this he
hardens his heart he sins again you know
this is inevitable
and so now we have uh the plague of
locus and the way it's represented
listen carefully that the Lord said to
Moses go to Pharaoh for I've hardened
his heart and the Heart of his officials
so that I may perform these signs of
mine along among them you may tell your
children and grandchildren how I dealt
harshly with the Egyptians and how I
perform my signs among them and that you
may know that I am the Lord so Moses and
Aaron went to fair and said
this is what the Lord the god of the
Hebrew says how long will he refuse to
humble yourself before me let my people
go so that they may worship me if you
refuse to let them go I will bring
locusts into your country tomorrow it
will cover the face of the ground so
that it cannot be seen they will devour
what little you have left after the hell
including every tree that is growing in
your Fields it will fill your houses and
all of your of all your officials and
and the Egyptians something neither your
parents nor your ancestors have ever
seen from the day they settled in this
land until now
Pharaoh's official said to him how long
will this man be a snare to us let the
people go so that they may Worship the
Lord their God do you not realize that
Egypt is ruined
so then Moses and Aaron were brought
back to pharaoh go worship your God and
he said but tell me who will be going so
Moses says we will go with our young and
our old and our sons and our daughters
and with our flocks and our herds
everybody is going now of course Pharaoh
you know fair is not completely stupid
he also knows that what's going on you
know it's not like it you have to be
able to read the story both ways it's
like the Pharaoh knows that if you go
everybody their livestock all the people
they're not coming back right then and
so he there's he's not completely
insensible and you know I think that he
should let the people go but you know
you can kind of put yourself in the
place to pharaoh and think like oh you
want to bring everybody all your things
and all everything that you own uh like
no if you do that obviously you're not
coming back and that ultimately in some
ways interestingly enough is God's plan
for this he does not want Israelite to
come back so it's interesting to think
about it that way as well
so he doesn't want so he says no you
know have only the men go and Worship
the Lord since that is what you've been
asking for
so Moses and Aaron were driven out of
the pharaoh's presence and so he the
Lord said to Moses stretch out your hand
over Egypt so that Locus swarm over the
land and devour everything growing in
the fields everything left by the hail
now then you wonder like why why locusts
now it's like okay so now it's another
insect that is coming we already had the
Flies we already had the gnats like
what's the difference between the Locust
but the way it's described you'll
understand if you see the pattern of how
it's basically moving from the bottom of
the world all the way up this is where
you'll see it because the way it's
described listen carefully so Moses
stretched out his staff over Egypt and
the Lord made an East wind blow across
the land that day and all that night and
by morning the wind had brought locusts
and so this is you have to remember that
the the wind is the spirit there in the
ancient Hebrew thinking these are the
same and so
the Lord made a spirit below across the
land and that spirit that wind brought
locusts and so now we're really in the
air now we really are as if it's the
wind itself which is coming bringing
these locusts with it from the East even
and now will that is what will destroy
the land of Egypt so it is a Heavenly
phenomena that is being represented it's
different from the gnats that Rose Up
Out of the Dust of the world to to do
something similar but now it is really
coming from above this wind that blows
and is undoing uh creation
all right verse 14 they invaded all
Egypt and settled down in every era of
the country in great Numbers Never
Before had there been such a plague of
locusts nor will there ever be again
they covered the ground until it was
black they devoured all that was left
after the hell everything growing in the
field and the fruit of the trees nothing
green remained on tree or plant in the
land of Egypt and this is I think it's
also representing the manner in which
Heaven also can Devour the world they're
different versions of that when when
things get unloosened when things start
to hold together there are images of
Heaven devouring the Earth usually a
predatory bird is represented the idea
of like a Rapture that comes and takes
um but then also now as these locusts
that can come in the spirit and land on
the on the earth and just devour
everything
so the way that it goes away is also to
suggest the notion that this is a
Heavenly phenomena uh because finally of
course Pharaoh says I've sinned you know
uh and he says take the plague away from
me and Moses prays to the Lord verse 19
and the Lord changed the wind to a very
strong West Wind which caught up the
locusts and carried them into the Red
Sea now the Locust was left in Egypt but
the Lord hardened Pharaoh's heart and he
would not let the Israelites go and so
now you have like basically the wind
carrying them and then dropping them
into the the lower Waters
so then the Lord said to Moses stretch
out your hand verse 21 toward the sky so
that Darkness spreads over Egypt so now
we have a really an undoing of the world
right we are moving back before the
light but now it is a plague of Darkness
it's as if you know the the very first
day of creation is being undone
stretch your hands over the sky to the
dark and spread over Egypt's darkness
that can be felt so Moses stretched out
his hand towards the sky and total
darkness covered out Egypt for three
days
three days it's important to understand
that there all of these things will
culminate in
the death of Christ you know a lot of
these images are culminating into the
the story of Christ no one could see
anyone else or move about for three days
yet all the Israelites had light in the
places where they lived
so Pharaoh turned to Moses go Worship
the Lord even your women and children
may go with you but only lead your
flocks and hurts behind and most like no
man
he says You must allow us to have
sacrifices and burnt offerings to
present the Lord of God our livestock
must go with us not a hoof is to be left
behind we have to use some of them in
worship of the Lord or God until we get
there we will not know what we are to
use to Worship the Lord
but the Lord hardened Pharaoh's heart
and he was not willing to let them go
Pharaoh said to Moses get out of my
sight make sure do not appear before me
again the day you will see my face
you will die
just as you say Moses replied I will
never appear before you again
so now we get to the final plague
now the Lord said to Moses I will bring
one more plague on pharaoh and on Egypt
after that he will let you go from here
and when he does he will drive you out
completely tell the people that men and
women alike are to ask their neighbors
for articles of silver and gold the Lord
made the Egyptians favorably disposed
towards the people and Moses himself was
highly regarded in Egypt by Pharaoh's
officials and by the people
so Moses said this is what the Lord says
and this is this if this is idea of
plundering the Egyptians which is
important in the in the theological
tradition which is uh
in the theological tradition there's
this idea in Saint Gregory of Nissa that
Egypt represents you know everything
that is exterior so on the one hand it
represents let's say our passions it
represents outer Authority it represents
but also represents something like
science and knowledge and education and
civilization itself you could say and so
this is all the things that Egypt
represents what I kind of bound up into
the symbolism of the garments of skin uh
and so there's a sense in which the
church fathers say that we should
plunder the Egyptians that means that we
should take from The Sciences from
wisdom from philosophy even from all the
things Pagan that which we can use in
service of God
uh and that so that we should leave
behind into the waters you could say of
the Dead Sea
of not of the density of the Red Sea we
can leave behind in the in the waters of
the Red Sea all of that of the Pagan
world and of the secular world and of
civilization which is dangerous to us
but with we can also gather into us and
carry with us that which is good and so
this is of course represented as the
Egyptian CIS the Egyptian mother the iso
Ethiopian wife the the midianite wife
all of these images of joining with the
stranger and now the notion of
plundering the Egyptians has to do with
this as well take what is Good from the
secular so
a little we'll get to it later but a
little side note here to understand this
is that the goal that they take from the
Egyptians and the stuff they take from
the Egyptians you have to understand
that this gold and stuff is what will be
used to make the Tabernacle so it will
be set you know in service of God but
it's also that which will be used to
make the golden calf so you can see the
two images of that which is taken from
the stranger from civilization from this
outer shell uh can be useful in the
service of God but then also can become
the
an idol if it is not dealt with properly
and of course this is the the same with
Aaron himself you know I presented in
the last lecture about how Aaron is
something like the helper uh this and
he's like an extension of Moses
you know Moses is God to him and then
he's like the prophet to the people and
then that extension has both sides you
know Aaron ends up being the priest in
the Tabernacle he is like an uh
ritualized and embodied expression of
that which is invisible
and so it's necessary and good that he
does that but then Mo Aaron is also the
one who makes the golden calf and so the
extension itself can be dangerous if it
is not directed in the right if you're
not pointed in the right direction okay
and so this is what plundering the
Egyptian is related to is at least in
many of the church fathers
so Moses says this is what the Lord says
about midnight I will go throughout
Egypt every firstborn in Egypt will die
for the firstborn of pharaoh who sits on
the throne to the firstborn son of the
female slave who is at her hand Mill and
all the firstborn of the cattle as well
there will be loud wailing throughout
Egypt worse than there has ever been or
will ever be again but among the
Israelites on a dog will bark at any
person or animal
then you will know that the Lord makes a
distinction between Egypt and Israel
all these officials of yours will come
to me bowing down before me saying go
you and all the people who follow you
after me
that I will leave after that I will
leave then Moses hot with anger left
pharaoh
so what I think is I think we're going
to stop here because we've already been
going for a while and the plague of the
firstborn I think is crucial I think the
plague of the firstborn and
understanding the death of the firstborn
and how it is embedded into the
structure of the Passover sacrifice
itself and how it is embedded into the
structure of sacrifice
just straight uh it's going to be
important to analyze and to understand
and it will help us also understand you
know the death of Christ and what it is
that why why is this the whole idea of
the sacrifice of the firstborn like why
is this so important what does it mean
and how can it help us understand the
way that reality lays itself out and so
I hope that this has been useful
everybody I hope that you are enjoying
this series on Exodus I know I am it's
uh it is definitely one of my favorite
books uh you know not the least because
of Saint Gregor venice's life of Moses
being one of my favorite books and so I
uh looking forward to continuing it and
I and I hope that you have a chance to
also check out The Exodus series on
daily wire so everybody talk to you very
soon